...
-Voici les clés pour le cas où
tu changerais d'avis.
A ta santé, à tes amours,
à ta folie.
Je vais tenir mes rêves au chaud
et le champagne au froid,
car je t'aime.
Et n'oublie pas les 18 mois
de Nicolas.
Voici les clés, ne les perds pas
sur le pont des Soupirs.
Elles sont en or,
on ne sait jamais, ça peut servir.
Ne t'en fais pas, j'ai ce qu'il
faut, on n'est jamais perdant
quand on aime.
J'ai mes bouquins
et ton petit chien,
eux sont contents.
Voici les clés de ton bonheur,
il n'attend plus que toi.
Appelle-moi si par bonheur
elles n'ouvraient pas.
Na na na, na na na...
Tu sais toujours où me trouver,
moi je ne bouge pas.
Moi je t'aime.
Et n'oublie pas la communion
de Nicolas.
Pas de chance,
j'allais t'emmener
en Italie,
en voyage d'amour.
Pas de chance,
moi je t'aime aussi
et depuis
bien plus longtemps
que lui.
Voici les clés de ton bonheur,
il n'attend plus que toi.
Tu sais toujours où me trouver,
moi je ne bouge pas.
Moi je t'aime.
Et n'oublie pas l'anniversaire
de Nicolas.
Voici les clés pour le cas où
tu changerais d'avis.
A ta santé, à tes amours,
à ta folie.
Na na na...
Je vais tenir mes rêves au chaud
et le champagne froid,
car je t'aime.
Et n'oublie pas l'anniversaire
de Nicolas.
Voici les clés, ne les perds pas
sur le pont des Soupirs.
Elles sont en or,
on ne sait jamais,
ça peut servir.